citizens of the reject Nation ah I got my two
Jews with me today who both had weird birthday
weeks as well oh and they don't know each other
that well whatsoever my hands are sweaty it's
all good you're welcome but you guys will find a
lot of commonality with this movie that actually
boomed the real reject so you guys better love
it regardless of whatever opinions I'm talking
to you Jew number one you're Jew number two today
I'm je one apparently hey first the worst second
the best okay I'll take it okay third is the
one with a hairy chest this is going to be
good I I'll let you guys get to it Roxy you're
here more you enter the video okay um here's my
mouse and here's my poster oh wait this isn't
room Raiders it's the raid yes I love it we're
here to watch the Raid a movie that literally
every film nerd references that I have never
seen is this your type of movie oh yeah I mean I
was a DI hard fan of the Daredevil Netflix show
and from the hallway scenes everyone always
Compares it to the raid so I'm like I got to
see you can't say die hard and then the raid you
know they're often compared just got to be like a
super fan of the raid I understood that reference
oh yeah cuz I'm very very clever you know who's
clever prepper thank you for editing all of our
videos cleverly we really appreciate you guys and
thank you to you for going over to patreon to
watch our full length watch along you can sync
up with us you super B sex and rejects Greg and
John cover several shows exclusively over there
with highlights and watch alongs include did gr
you can't stand and laugh at me alongside you
just can't I thought that was solid I'm pretty
sure I nailed it we're about to raid this raid
we're going to raid the raid I'm down to raid
the raid too let's do it no not raid to just
the raid one I was me meant as well but yes all
right I'll give you Redemption during the movie
[Music] you R you're just full of puns Roxy
yeah yes this is me at the gym every time I've
always wanted to be able to do one of those you
got to start on the Gravitron M machines and
then you work your way up to the real thing
I don't know the word you just used it's a
machine where you can decrease weight from
your body weight saying I have too much weight
yes that's exactly what I was saying you read it
correctly these movies always tend to have like
those crazy audio pops yeah D it's kind of like
is the itman intro with the yeah yeah no I was
thinking that where he does the super fast move
called something clearly we're well versed in
martial arts yeah we know our martial arts very
well the sound designer is really
good Stakes are immediately higher cuz she's
pagers that's a very concise baby
BM
all right I'll bring him back yeah it's
like some kind of mission he's got to go
on it's the new I'll be back I'll bring
him back that almost did sound like The
Terminator theme right there too as you say
that it's interesting to have your first movie
be called Redemption usually I feel like that
comes later that'd be the second or third film
yeah
oh these subtitles are going so fast I'm so
slow I want to see him tear
down walls the other's Andy
these are them I think so let's go ramen noodles
that's how you know they're really dangerous when
they're eating ramen noodles I guess that was
the most dangerous in college then every day
twice a day ramen noodles are pretty bomb not
GNA lie oh no oh he's gone he's dead bummer damn
oh it's like it man and John Wick had a
baby I hope that there's a bullet
in there and he takes it and he
kills him God the suspense of waiting
oh no the hammer is worse there's a
scene from Casino have you seen
that yeah oh the H to the hand
oh oh oh
boy they're introducing us
to a lot of characters really
fast all right let's do it yeah the music is
killer in this so far I think if they just
take away the ramen noodles he'll be defenseless
against them who are you focusing on right now
everybody I just want to make sure the main guy
who's got the baby at home yeah he surv that's
your dude obviously like everyone to survive but
yeah specifically him in the subtitle his name is
Rama oh they're
newbies this is a good first test in this
situation new recruits or whatnot his team why
is this guy in no helmet like is your head safe
he's like I'm so good I don't need a helmet yeah
don't get cocky though you get killed that was
your opportunity to have a little Han Solo don't
get cocky I was thinking more I'm not cocky I'm
confident so when you tell me I'm the best it's a
compliment the CP is working too
go very Bleak even when you're armed to
the teeth like that just in general it's
got to be so terrifying to go in
these types of situations if you I
would think it'd be more terrifying
even if you are dressed up as a
badass you know I've watched this in years from
movies I've never been able to get my I'm pretty
good at this oh are you yeah okay allegedly
allegedly so they're going to walk in and
find all these dead bodies on the ground that
wouldn't surprise me that's your interpretation
of where we are though I wouldn't even be
shocked if he has some inside guys on the
team a does this man deserved to
die
ah cool shot I love the way he came out of
the Shadows like that it's like batman-esque
you don't hear
them good cop bad cop yeah well he
can also sympathize with him is he
a wife only people with wives can sympathize
yeah exactly anyone else has no Humanity in
them I'm really loving the cinematography so
far that's funny I was just thinking
about the score ah well that too is
badass but where is the
ramen he crapped himself are you fully
understanding why they're taking these
prisoners I think they're they just they
work for the main guy well I think they
said earlier in the movie he's letting a bunch
of druggies and low life pushers and all that
yeah he's gonna run bummer
SC oh no no don't shoot him bummer
oh he's going to get killed right
now oh what a shot
damn well didn't help the situation
because he got it he got to tell them
it was police if you're going to
shoot him you needed to shoot him
earlier not that I'm advocating
for shooting children early yeah
yeah all right this kid needs to unfreeze I
mean after watching I would assume it's his
brother or friend get shot like I could
understand his apprehension to not stay
still
yeah wow homie doesn't give an f yeah he's
not worried those are the scariest type of
villains this is giving me some dread Vibes
I haven't seen it ah it's a great film you
should insert comment here Roxy hasn't
seem dread that needs to be the next one I
agree what cool architecture yeah oh snipers yeah
oh oh damn that's like a sniper's dream hole glory
hole that's interesting not showing
it but letting us hear the screams
well they're letting everybody
else hear the screams yeah yeah
yeah oh damn oh the
eyeball no no no are you an idiot I
get that you're sad but are you an
idiot oh snake is quite the Escape
yeah
yeah jeez this is so
tense but you're sitting there what do you do
duck yeah I wouldn't know how to react in that
situation you know that shot reminds me of Robocop
when Mr Kenny got from Ed 209 just got blown to
bits oh the gun behind him oh [__]
ooh a feeling it's only going to be
like one or two cops left at by the end
yeah it's going to be the main two dudes right
I would assume so be my guess and maybe the
non-helmet guy yeah but he's the first one that
shot the kid he doesn't deserve to be any of
the main he's not going to live through
the movie but he might live through the
scene
[Music]
creepy wow that's quite the proposition
free rent get rid of the insects they
should just get some raid to
get rid of the insects raid
no you can't honey what yeah why what is
it like a not sanctioned maybe yeah it's
my guess where he doesn't trust the rest of the
police department yeah nobody that was not wise
H are they military or are they they were
cops I thought they were cops clearly that
dude has never seen any movies cuz you never
not let other people know about the mission
yeah oh damn I think we're in
trouble the score is like one of the greatest
scores that I've heard in a long
time it really builds suspense and
tension wait oh God o oh what do you [Music]
whoa ooh Shadow shot y'all are screwed
City oh no no helmet dude where is your
helmet they want their free rent yeah
listen I get a la rent oh it's too high
it's crazy I wouldn't kill for it but probably
getting a bar fight or something yeah yeah
yeah burn them with the
trucks wonder if it's like a personal mission
for the guy who doesn't have a helmet because
why wouldn't he like let the rest of the
department know that they're doing this
right oh boy does he see him I think he does
but they're like in a no win
situation right now [Music]
woo movie is obviously called called The Raid do
you think this entire thing is about the raid of
this one place I it has to be you think we're
here the whole time the whole movie I would
guess my how the tables have
turned they went to raid the
place and now they're worried about getting
raided all the people near the Windows like
got to be a trapo around here somewhere
any looking for any exit he's smart yeah
I love how resourceful he is yeah
that's it that's it look under the
rug like all these pull-ups were not for
nothing do you think there are monitors
in this room felt like they were more in
the corridors and the hallways I don't
know if he had them actually in rooms
but you never know he owns the place
so can somebody go help him try to bang down
this floor feels like it' be a good use of your
resources oh
wow wait Jack's got to survive so we got
to help him wow that was a cool tracking
shot oh my
God this is intense o o o that
pickaxe woo that's a nice tackle
oh how many of us do you think are left how
many what the cops oh I think there's only a
couple oh no oh
no damn shoot his ear off
the sound design is I just can't stop
talking about it I know it's it's so good
oh what is he making like a bomb oh he's trying
to make it heavier if they shoot at it it'll
explode I don't know or maybe he's just making it
heavier to keep the thing close or oh yeah I guess
yeah damn
yeah won't penetrate through
the oh oh yeah there we go I was
sick going to say they also could have exploded
the place jumped into the
fridge like Indiana Jones
he's way too chill but an evil F telling you
it's the villains who are the most cist are
the ones who scare me the most because
you know there's rage penting up in
there yeah I wonder what the backstory
with him and no helmet guy is yeah oh my
God oh God the makeup in this film is
insane
ooh like I'll put you out your
misery oh the ear
yeah how do you keep calm when you're
in so much pain pain I know and you
can't hear it's probably that ringing sound or no
I don't know actually what it is it's
a probably a combination of pain and
ring this score is so good don't take
my line hey it's Hollywood we steal
here you're only allowed to care about the
cinematography and I'm only allowed to care
about the sound of hey talk to Steph I get I
say who what music is good ask her she'll tell
you you see a hand you take it I
mean damn that was wild shot almost looks like
he was like a hologram in the tour this is so
intense I would not want to be the
cleanup crew for this right yeah
it's got to be free rent or I don't clean this
up this guy just put on a hockey
mask he could be like Jason
Vorhees that's my guy oh this one
yeah
oh wonder if he's ever been in
a dire situation as this one the
actor no no no I just meant the the
yeah the actor yes you mean like what
were these characters up to before this
what's the prequel yeah I want to see the
prequel you think a lot of bullets are out you
think they're just tapped I mean yeah they fired a
lot
wait wait
wait what you build all that suspense and
then cut to another that's interesting
choice
oh yes
oh oh my God this dude's such a bad ass yeah
he's dope he's got something
worth fighting for you know
yeah I like how everybody who comes after
him has to make a big sound before they come
so it's like well it's like tennis you got
to make big sounds before you hit the ball
totally jeez oh my God the the choreography the
cinematography that's giving me some Daredevil
Netflix Vibes maybe they took it from that
[Music]
[Music] this
for lack of better words it's cool that we
started with guns because yeah then like we
escalated to this which those were amazing but
this is even better better yeah exactly the hand
toand choreography is so good sometimes it
gets too repetitive in a movie and this is
like every different floors different levels
different layers yeah it's funny you say that
cuz as the gunfighting was going I'm like I
hope we get a lot of hand toand choreography
now I got to imagine too the main villain Tom
I believe his name is if he's watching this
on surveillance I'd want to recruit this guy
but like leave him alive I want him on my our
team
intens you don't want to get shot
with your own gun yeah it's okay if
you get shot with someone else else's but not your
own okay so I believe there's five left
are you counting him that guy you mean
yeah yeah well I guess four and a half
oh we can't stand so it's good four and a
quarter yeah oh you got one and
you threw it I was going to say
you should maybe still save that one still
a bullet a bullet yeah what he's like dude
I got these these are my guns I feel like
that bullet's going to come back to haunt
him it's
whoever's oh the wife if this film did come out
before dread which I assume it did like they
really took a lot from dread took a lot from this
what year was dread 2012 I don't know what year
this think this was 2011 okay not positive though
they took a lot from it which is fine I mean
oh hide them oh that's quite the trap
door I'll bleed
you got scary eyes yeah he does and he barely
blinks
me too I hate
liars oh my God that is such a cool
shot sir what are we going
to watch for TV tonight thank
you oh my this feels like a horror film now
he's going to come back with blood on yeah he's
gonna say is he going to notice blood on his
machete hey dude wipe the blood
off that thing that's what I was
just thinking cuz that guy will for sure notice
that I don't want to see it ah ah ah
oh yeah he's going to notice the
blood he's trying to clean it did
he yeah and the wall you have to be so
mentally tough to not squirm or make a
noise when being even a little
bit sliced by a machete in the
face oh what that bullet I think
so the level of pain that man is feeling
from there and there I I yeah what you
got going on is he going to take these
two guys out because he wanted to do it
alone oh wow why cuz then he gets a better deal or
maybe to prove himself that
he can do by himself he said
why was going to be so graic remember he
said to the guy Tama he was like why are
you doing this so maybe he's on their team
maybe he thinks it's bad what they're doing
either that or he just wants to prove he can
do by himself I don't think so cuz he was not
happy with Tama oh yeah cuz he kept saying like
they're going to call reinforcements right right
right T feels like the more dangerous
version of the monkey in Toy Story 3
that was watching all them on surveillance from
Escape in daycare your references are
wild I know right that's what I've been
told oh no oh it's on like Donkey
Kong take his weapon you need
something cuz you threw away
the the one bullet [Applause] yeah oh boy
oh who jeez but grab the
weapon and probably also not to
get in trouble right yeah combo of
both
whoa Jesus that would be the most uncomfortable
death oh my god oh he's the man bro yeah
badass status like if I look up badass
in the dictionary there's going to be a picture
of him uh out the window you go oh he goes with
[Music] them use him as a
shield oh no this dude is built like a brick
wall what did you just come into
though look around excuse me the
sky all right back together back
together no no we're on the same
side oh it's the guy that you that
you said he took cut the two in the
elevator they know each other they're
Brothers I don't know I you could be
R yeah yep he deserves
that my man I can see why now
don't be careful nope keep it
going yep yeah I was going to say
in this situation it's like what
yep yep lean in tell him yep
y answer him be wise wear a
helmet clearly he has some
but let's go get our men
uh oh uh oh uh oh knew it yeah he came
out too strong it's like don't just walk
out the door man he's Jacka he's he
can do anything what is a gun versus
knife is Jacka The Inside guy
oh that feels like the first unrealistic
moment of the movie compared to the rest
of the movie like I'm happy about it cuz
I want to see them fight but yeah yeah
who oh that guy's a little Legend
you can see why he's confident not
wanting to shoot him yeah but still
like it's the sure bet there's no
lead up to that at all we didn't
see this guy all the time do that
like oh needed nose oh you really feel these
punches sound design what did I tell
you it's my thing stealing your your
lines okay I'm going to need to look at that face
every day so you're going to have to not beat him
up like that cuz it's my man you think Jo
is gonna die right now no no no no no no
[Music] no I hope the old dude comes in and
saves him no helmet dude or just the main star
yeah him too no three two a no really liked
him I'm sorry he was my man I'm done with the
movie
you better hope they don't see him on surveillance
with him he knows where the surveillance
is their dad yeah okay so they are
brothers I'm brilliant you no one said you
weren't now we have to survive
dude has no
fear oh the guy is the old
guy without the helmet all
right I'm hopeful to look wait wait look
look look any sign of detection of Life
maybe move your foot move your foot do it
ver Roxy come on Jaa there's no way right
I he broke his neck pretty the way I unless
he's super human I'd be okay with that pot
twist how do you know
this he blood on his hands from the two guys he
[Music] G take the knife for
something no no I knew it I knew
the hand I need a hand I need
the this is my kind of party right here oh yeah
Dr
I want to see a a bag of white
powder like it's just all
over hey is this guy actually doing
something I want to know about him
I'm sure it will be revealed but
like what's up with him and Tama
what's your guess watch their
brothers I'm just kid I have no
idea he must have used to work for the
organization or something but then we also
heard that he's doing it for money maybe
I mean Jaa said someone's trying to get
rich well it makes the uh production designer's
job a lot easier one location I don't know that
they shot it in one location this very
likely a completely different place good
point wow wow that kid has one resilient
father I mean if anyone can survive a neck
snapping it's definitely Chaka in my opinion
that was a good table scene oh no here's his
[Music] brother but this isn't the 15th floor
right oh his brother's getting beat up you
didn't get my refence I got pe's on my head
but don't call me a p head his name's Andy
like Andy milanus whatever just can't leave
a comment if you got it cuz he likes a fair
fight now actually the other thing makes this
better because are they going two on one cuz
we know he likes a fair fight so we let him go
from the thing his character makes more sense
too so this is the sidekick
that they said would burn
you or whatever it was remember
at the beginning when they were
talking do he had a bullets we
obviously know each other well
and he's s rep playing this game he's been
paying him off I think Tom has been paying no
helmet yeah but why did he do it in the
first place why did he have them raid in
the first place you know cuz then he wanted out
but he figured then he couldn't do it I think he
overestimated the the situation thought that
they were going to be able to take them down
easily yes
Redemption o this dude is Savage and
ruthless team work makes the dream I was
just thinking that come on brothers let's go
Brothers I kind of like this guy he took out
your man I know well I still think my Man's
Alive oo music's getting
tenser oh no don't do the neck break oh
no Brother come on through come on through
brother brother come through brother where
you at Andy Andy wake up Andy get up Andy
hello oh is he going to stab him yeah get
there quicker baby I know your hand hurts
Andy and I think probably the rest of your body
too yeah I would say he's in immense pain all
over where's ear guy I think he got his
neck oh he's going to kill him he saved
his brother's life and then he's going
to H push the thing in his neck still
fighting with it in his neck push the thing
in his night neck more no no no poor Andy ah
this is the sickest fight this is like a jail
cell fight yeah work together Brothers rip him
apart how is this dude have any energy
to still keep fighting with that in his
neck oh both his arms oh
yeah yeah yeah [Music] a yes
yes o rip it right across all right but
mad respect to this guy that was quite
the fight that's what I mean like I don't
actually like him but got to respect him
that was quite the battle actually like I
don't know if we do have to respect him it
seems like he's done some really horrible
things but I just meant as a fighter like
damn
right he's got to Die the most painful death
ever oh okay I'm not getting it he
was going to replace him apparent
I think that's what he's saying but the
guys who sent him yeah but who's razza
I think the guys who are in charge
of him like he's going to shoot him
he's going to shoot him yeah there we like
if my life is over I'm just going to take
you out right now so I think he was sent
in there by a he's a collector and he was
going to either take his place or get it
for the guys who sent him in but the guys
who sent him actually wanted him dead and
called to give the heads up yeah yeah it
was a setup from the beginning he but did
we meet Reza I don't think so I think he's
shoot himself yeah I think so but maybe
they stop him or maybe there's no bullet
[Music]
like s's in charge
now the guy with the ears probably like what
y'all know each other or what like dude the
whole point of the mission was to get your
brother and he's not coming with you ah that
sucks they already knew they needed a raid too
[Music] I really feel bad for arama though like
again whole motivation was getting his brother
out no I mean I think he also wanted to do the
job it's his job he's a cop also too I think it
wasn't just get his brother out but he also he
knew that they were going to attack where Andy was
so he's like I got to make sure nothing happens to
him even if I don't get him out yeah keep him
safe yeah okay so I guess he accomplished one
part of his mission but he did say I'll bring
him home the guy who deserved to die die the
most ends up living I feel like he might stay
or something I mean no he's got a wife and kid
I don't mean to run the place but do something
maybe not he's a man of Duty yeah you're right
cut who's the Redemption for Andy I don't know
damn that was a really good one yeah oh I don't
think I don't think there was enough action though
what I mean yeah totally that's definitely it I
mean for of the uh action movies you've seen in
the last decade or so where does this kind of rank
up for you I mean it's definitely right up there
yeah me too um yeah I've NE I mean it wasn't it
it wasn't just think we're on to something else
here we just let it ride yeah okay uh it wasn't
it wasn't just that um the action was Exhilarate I
mean it's just like it was nonstop it was tense to
steal your line the sound design you felt every
punch you felt every bullet that was being shot
and the scoring oh the score was great it really
did a good J like you already felt the scenes
building up with tension and suspense just from
what was happening visually but the music like
really ramped it up even more so are two major
payoffs were the fact that they were brothers
right or I guess our reveals the fact that they're
brothers and the fact that uh no helmet was either
going to take over or whatever it was he was
a bad a dirty cop which we kind of knew the
whole time but we found out more about did both
those land for you I would say the brother one
for sure the yeah that was definitely a good one
the one with the the cop it was I mean I was just
more invested in the action at that point that I
mean whether that landed I don't know if that one
landed for me per se it was kind of like a little
bit obvious but either way whether it was obvious
or not um I don't know if it landed but I I was
again because I was so into the action I didn't
really care whether it landed for me or not yeah
I feel you but yeah know I mean if I mean if I'm
a Hollywood producer and I have an action film I'm
finding the stunt choreographer for this film and
the fight choreographer and I'm making sure that
they are I'm paying them whatever they want and
they're going to work on my film but like I said
you can tell there's a lot of inspiration like
when I watch Winter Soldiers Civil War definitely
dread uh Daredevil the Netflix uh show I mean you
can tell a lot they've clearly the people who
worked on that watch this if if they didn't
hire the people that were already working on this
they watch that and like let's attempt to do this
as best we can because this is should be the
gold standard for how fight choreography and
action should be and not only films in General
but especially if films here in the states I am
curious because it it just seems so much like it
was then we were in such closeup shots and then
such like VI visually um clear wides that I feel
like there's no way that these were stunt doubles
for any shots and maybe that's why they were able
to do what they were able to do and and not in
some other movies or shows that's that's a good
point I mean I'm sure it makes life so much easier
when you're coming up with these elaborate fight
choreograph scenes knowing that all these actors
can do what we need them to do we don't need to
put stunt doubles or whatever in like unless they
did and I'm completely wrong but it did not seem
that way to me I'm with you it really felt like
all the ACT especially the main ones too but it
felt like all the actors were doing their own
stunts and own fights um so yeah no I mean the
this is definitely one of the best action just
pure action it's one of the best action films
ever and again was so tense like you never had
a moment to relax and chill it just continuously
kept on going like every every time you felt like
I'm getting a second it's like no next one next
one next one but they did pause at really poignant
moments like even you're you're feeling like okay
it's been fight after fight after fight that one
hallway thing where we're looking there's four
people standing down and he's like all right I
know what's coming right now it it it's nice to
have those moments or like when the brother pulls
them into the room and they I think that they
really carefully picked those times to ramp up and
when to just let it breathe for a second so that
it didn't always feel one note yeah no you make a
great point they did and they specifically picked
uh scenes that uh were really smart in terms of
when they did that because even in those moments
I still felt like the action could be ramped up
at any second I never for a second felt CA relaxed
for any especially Rama and those character like
I always felt like they're always in some type of
danger or something crazy is about to happen yeah
so even when when they have those moments that
you're talking about like just because again
they're specifically picking moments where uh you
know they're they're taking a second to let us
breathe for a second and get some Exposition or a
reveal going you still always feel like action can
happen at any which time and you never feel for a
second that characters are safe um do you have an
action sequence that stood out to you obviously
a lot for different reasons but when you think
about this movie is there one you're going to
remember everything but I think specifically if
I'm thinking one it's that two one fight the
two brothers versus I mean that's i' just in
a box yeah there was like nothing to distract
us um at the second he pulls the chain up and
you're realizing this is just a square room with
three men fighting till one or two of them die I
would have I agree with you I would have thought
that they would have had Rama and him oneon-one
but if you think about like think about all that
Rama had been through up until that point he's got
to be so worn down and tired at that point from
what he's survived through and whereas that guy
other than taking out your man he really hasn't
done too much paddling so he's a lot more well
rested but still that scene even two onone I also
wouldn't have necessarily believed that Rama was
a better fighter solo even if he wasn't exhausted
than um the yo mama I don't know what his name is
the little guy he is such a fierce fighter and to
see him take out my man we know that he is and we
describe the lore around him going into this right
he is the number one he's the best fighter we know
he's better than Andy because when we're talking
about it that's what he's described as Andy has a
different description this guy has that that lore
he can beat anybody yeah no I I agree with you and
also too he doesn't when you just look at him you
would not think he's such an imposing fighter so
like the reveal of just seeing how good he really
is yeah disrespect of me referring to him as the
little guy because I don't know his name I just
want you guys to know I think the best things in
small packages so I mean it with all the honor in
the world uh what do we get a character name for
him if we did I don't remember I just I remember
Rama I remember Tama I remember jaku uh jaka there
we go exactly uh uh Andy yeah and yeah the and
then there's uh the ear we called him ear guy we
called him no helmet guy then there's treacherous
no helmet guy yes why do you think that the ear
guy lived um well I mean they got the bll no it's
just interesting that of all of the characters
just like of all the people there's three there's
four people that live total right uh Andy who
stays and then our three people which is dirty
cop no helmet wearing Rama and ear guy I think
they're like the writers are like we've given this
man enough pain and torture we're going to let him
have to live the rest of his life with this I'm
not just saying this because he's my man but I
wish my man made it out I really do like I feel
like if you were gonna have if you were because
we know that there's another one if you were
gonna have not if you were gonna have more than
just Rama make it out yeah I would have loved to
see Rama and it sounded to me like when Rama was
talking to Andy he said I've been having to listen
All Day to my best friends talk about killing you
and I took that as uh he's talking about my man as
his best friend they seemed like good cop bad cop
but they seemed like the two coming into this so
I would have lik to see a sequel with that Dynamic
of now that guy learning that Rama and Andy and
again this was like amazing the way that they did
it but I am curious when they were figuring out
okay ear dudes got to make it through interesting
choice no I mean yeah you make a good point but
I am curious as the dynamic between uh jaka and
did I say that right this time yeah okay good Jaa
and Rama I'm curious is their dynamic because I
there was tension too yeah yeah but also too
because at the beginning with no helmet guy
he was saying this is the team you picked out a
bunch of I think he said a bunch of rookies and
stuff so I am curious he did describe him as his
best friends oh did he he when he was talking to
I know what you mean because he did say this
is a bunch of rookies but when he was talking
to Andy Rama said I listen to my best friends
that also could be a translation thing no no
you're probably translation could have meant to
be like my colleagues I was still processing so
much information at once but no you're probably
right so um I think also two as much as I would
have loved to have seen him survive I think the
whole pointk I think the whole point of why they
did that was to show that no one is safe obviously
and also to like this man is not to be trifled
with he can take out anyone yeah the stakes were
very high there did you want to see any combat
from um the Tama yeah I was thinking that it's and
it's fine you said I was thinking I would have but
I mean but he was almost more menacing that way
right like that's not his role he everybody are
is henchmen I mean yeah he's got people in place
for that was like the way he came off just where
he was really like silent about him and just like
more calm and then like he had that moment where
he exploded with Andy like he scared the crap out
of me from that to the point where I don't really
need to see I mean if he would have fine but I
didn't need to see that it didn't bother me that
he wasn't in a hand toand combat fight yeah I'm
I'm with you I think that it actually made for
more powerful everybody else was doing that it's
like when you have a script and everybody's funny
and you're like well not everybody's funny you
know some people would be funny it's in this not
everybody's a fighter and he's the one in charge
of everything I understand completely why this
movie is as popular as it is I was thinking that
watching this wow this makes perfect sense I get
why this is referenced on every action list I
guess I get why this is referenced on a lot of
foreign film lists I get why all the film critics
I respect like this is the one this is if you
love combat this is what you need to be watching
watching this I was thinking maybe it was going to
be overhyped for me and then I was watching like
yeah they just they nailed it they annihilated
this movie I mean if I'm ever making an action
film I'm watching this m like this is the gold
standard we got to be not so much to say copy
this but we got to be in line with this whether
it comes to the fight choreography the editing
the I mean just everything was so on point when
it comes to action so yeah yeah I know for years
too I'd been hearing Craig had been saying to me
like you need to watch the Raid I mean I got to
itman which I loved uh I did that here it was
unbelievable oh my God that one fight scene where
he's fighting like 10 10 guy oh my God that scene
I remember watching that for the first time that's
the one I had heard about going into it yeah and
then this too now like oh my God and again like
i' I've said not to sound like a broken record
there's definitely you can tell that there's
been inspiration some Hollywood films in terms of
action uh films that they have again inspired that
when I watch this I'm like oh I really see this in
that film and in that film and in that film and I
can understand why I would want to try to emulate
as much as I possibly could without feeling like
I'm coping but just more of like being respectful
and we're going to execute like they are doing
here in this film because that was just one of
the best not I'm not talking story just in terms
of pure action that's one of the best action films
I've ever seen in my life yeah I hear you if this
was an American film I think that we would have
ended on Rama coming back to his pregnant wife
yeah and but we ended with him saying goodbye to
his brother did you like the place that this ended
or do you wish that we got some kind of a reunion
I mean yeah I would have liked him to uh to get
back to his I mean we know that he's going to
get back to his wife I think that would have been
could be a bumpy train ride we don't know yeah but
uh it's going to be interesting when we do get to
the sequel where I mean I I got to assume Andy and
Rah are both going to be in it uh an ear dude we
got to see him back hopefully Jacka please he's if
anyone can survive a neck breaking it's jock I why
did I feel like his eyes were gonna just pop open
his body's getting dragged I just wanted it to be
like Twitchy like a little bit I don't know I was
hope I really did like his character a lot I mean
he's a man of honor and like I I really did love
that like again getting away from the action I
really did love that scene where he stood up to no
helmet guy I'm like uh dude your ranking doesn't
mean [__] like we're gonna we're going to save
guys I don't care how insanely crazy it is like
you can either stay here or you follow us I don't
give a [__] logistically speaking Yeah can a
human survive their neck getting [Music] snap
this is a good question for let us know let us
know in the comments any final burning words
on the Raid Redemption I I love this film so so
much uh again wasn't the deepest storyline but I
was so invested in the action that I didn't care
but again had a nice little twist in terms of the
the brother reveal um I just again I've never seen
action quite like that it was really exhilarating
to watch the music the cinematography the sound
design I know I'm stealing all your lines um but
seriously it it really was incredible to watch it
was just I I just I can't believe that they were
able to accomplish this it's really amazing I I
wish Hollywood films could do this consistently
um yeah there's a lot of great action films too
here in Hollywood um but you're in Hollywood
not quite to this level well radi or not then
that's the end I'm usually a pun Queen I feel
like I really love you did good on this one no I
dropped the ball there's got to be so many raid
like parade raid like your Trader I don't know
you you think Ty yeah uh CR CR now you got you
got to think of a bunch now the Cradle to the
gra you got to think a much now for the sequel
okay time now well hopefully then we get enough
likes comments all that stuff to get to the sequel
uh let us know if you think of anything puntier
than I just did and how you felt about the raid
I'm sure you guys have probably seen it before
because we're the last two people on the planet
to watch this uh but you guys are the best thank
you reject and we'll see you next time [Music]